second-quarter earnings per share of a
dollar ninety missing the consensus
estimate by ten cents so eps in the
second quarter of a dollar ninety
missing the consensus as for that iphone
the number of iphones the company sold
50 1.2 million iphones in the second
quarter higher than what analysts were
looking for so that is a good number
because of course the iphone is driving
everything at Apple right now its
outlook for the third quarter revenue 41
to 43 billion dollars so coming in shy
again of analysts estimates so another
disappointing outlook although apples
notorious for giving conservative
guidance the consensus estimate was 447
point four billion dollars for third
quadrant we're also seeing a person
increased a quarterly dividend and the
share repurchase authorization now up to
175 billion dollars hey guys want to
jump it to the guidance for gross margin
to what Shanna was just mentioning
really disappointing here there's a key
number for this company this company has
been able to keep its gross margins
really high at least over the last
decade or so gross margins were
expecting to be about thirty nine
percent that would've been in Lionel
that we'd seen before they're saying in
the third quarter gross margins are come
come down to 37 and a half to
thirty-eight percent so a midpoint of of
37 and three quarters for gross margins
and that's a disappointment there I
think but it could reflect the
introduction of a new phone a new
smaller phone with gross margins might
not be as good but that was a key number
a lot of people looking for can they
keep gross and margins up as introduces
smaller iPhone that they announced a few
weeks back right clear the sign right
there is no and that's sentence bad news
by the markets right now right are they
willing to sacrifice margin here as they
have to continue to sustain it their
share their market share one thing of
course that we find really interesting
as well Joe with Apple is the other
product segment right it's kind of
nebulous it includes iTunes it includes
the watch it includes all those other
things the Apple really needs to develop
to kind of take some of the reliance off
of the iphone two point one nine billion
dollars for the quarter not a lot when
you consider how much money Apple brings
in overall fifty point six billion
dollars of revenue overall that's
compared with four point three five
billion dollars in the first quarter so
apples other products revenue really
dropping off there presumably to the
Apple watch I'm not sure meanwhile on
your screen you're seeing the post
market tick by tick action the stock off
4.7 currently what
I gotta say is pretty close to that what
the options market was expecting 4.6
three percent so options markets looking
out right in line